j'avais sauté de là où tu montes jesse
je te montre la membrane
ça marche c'est quoi ce nom 6 à 2 g rc2
sinon je te voit sauter jkr qui s'arrête
le battait tous saturés pis comment
quand on est des plus magnifiques
voitures de bach madame bovary du proie
c'était la vie d'avant ce jeu là c'est
même jeu le pire est très rester ici
toute la nuit
janis hawk espace étrange
ça a mal fini tout ça
vous m'avez coffret tout le monde va le
savoir de lui faire ravaler
tu as retrouvé ma force cette belle
place
j'ai plongé
et cette peur du montre deux fois joseph
trop de fois je gamberge altaï
je voudrais qu'à les prendre et notre
ère avant que notre rares yves pour nous
gagner